this my friends is the system that
changed my life
this is the system i started to follow
10 years ago wasn't sexy at the time but
i just started to do the steps and do
the work and implement the habits and
the daily routines
welcome to the think media podcast my
name is heather torres the host of this
show and here we want to help you grow
your influence on youtube and then turn
that influence into a high impact and a
high income online business and today
i'm excited because we're gonna be
breaking down our seven step system for
success on youtube now if you were not
tuned in to our last episode that was
part one of this two-part series and i
really recommend that you listen to that
one first so maybe go back and listen
and then come back to this episode but
if you're already caught up and ready to
go then you are in the right place so
make sure you have a pen and paper ready
because we're diving into how to help
you get fierce clarity on this next
season for you in your youtube journey
and really in your whole online business
so lean in it's time to get into the
second part of this keynote from sean
cannell
so i asked this question in light of
these four trends
ultimately there's so much opportunity
it's a real gold rush people are
crushing it but what's the difference
between those that are crushing it and
thriving and and those that are
struggling ultimately online and what i
found out that
that there's multiple different ways you
could solve a problem
we got problems how am i going to create
all this content we got problems how am
i going to you know start making videos
when i got other stuff to do in my life
i got i got maybe work i got kids we got
problems and when it comes to solving
problems there's some good solutions
some solutions are are are not as good
or bad and some solutions are absolutely
terrible right just because we have a
problem people approach it different
ways so we need to figure out what's the
best way to really crush it with online
video but the truth is the reason a lot
are struggling is because they're going
about it the wrong way and so i actually
want to look at a couple different ways
to solve problems and you tell me if
it's a good idea or a terrible idea
here's one
this is the closed-hanger muffler fix
i mean that's a way to solve the problem
like ultimately right i mean i don't
know
that's one how about the duct tape drink
holder
genius i mean somebody yeah i mean
i it looks like it's working uh it maybe
solves the problem of holding your drink
but it doesn't solve the problem of
impressing your date i don't know i mean
how about the the duct tape hammock
would you trust that
would you trust that
how about the
beater baby carrier
i this is this is a great idea you know
i got another boy on the way and uh that
that
that's smart that that looks that's
great
how about the the fan leaf blower
just different ways to solve problems i
mean this is a conference about
innovation you know you got to get
creative right
what about um what about the two dollar
spoiler
here's one
this is the flat screen tv installation
this is a way to solve the problem i
mean all you got to do
easy
right
the funny thing is jen's ears in the
room they're like they don't even know
like what why is the tv that big
like i grew up i had this sony wiga flat
screen but glass tv it weighed 2 000
pounds
it was 27 inches you remember that you
thought carry it like you break it it's
done it just absolutely shatters right
and so here's the thing
uh i've stumbled now over the years on
on a better way to get consistent
results with video
like we we we all kind of have the same
problems honestly like we're trying to
figure out how to create content uh but
i there but some are gonna solve them
well and some not as well and honestly
what i've discovered is not just a
better way to get consistent results in
life and video but this will apply to
business and life and i found it in this
book called atomic habits anybody read
this book
man great book and and here's here's the
big aha moment for me that those who
those who struggle
they focus on goals
but those who win
they focus on systems
they focus on systems
i'll come back to that but listen see
your goal is a desired income but your
system is the collection of daily habits
that'll get you there
all right and so ultimately the problem
with goals is this
you know
problem number one is that winners and
losers both have goals
if you think about it like like like i
can imagine maybe some of our goals in
this room like what's your goal in this
room oh i want to get a million
subscribers
i want to get that silver play button
yo i want to be able to i want to get
gary vee on my podcast right we have the
same goals
well goals are good but but but winners
and losers have the same goals
but when you have a system a system is
the habits and the routines and the
things we're gonna learn at this
conference that gets you to the goal
like a goal is good but a system is
better the thing too with a goal as a
goal is a momentary change
and here's some good news and kind of
some bad news about online video
i'm not asking you to just do like
one thing for a little while
like get some subscribers and then you
can focus on the next thing
this has to become a lifestyle
this is the new world the new world is
you got to embrace content creation you
got to find a way to incorporate it in
your daily routines if you're looking
like i'm going to do a little video
sprint and then just let the results
happen no like this is a way of life of
online marketing of building your
business of getting comfortable on
camera of creating content consistently
that's why we need a system
and and that might sound overwhelming
but the system actually will reduce
stress and will reduce overwhelm here's
problem three with goals is they
actually are at odds with long-term
progress
if you're too preoccupied with goals
it's just pie in the sky but if we
actually just look at the simple small
steps and work the system then one day
we look up and all of a sudden it's like
dang dude
now we're throwing a conference and some
people actually showed up
because honestly for me i've just been
working the system and james claire said
this you don't rise to the level of your
goals you fall to the level
of your systems see friend the secret is
the system the secret is the system if
you want to kill overwhelm and create
profitable content in less time you need
a system if you want to eliminate time
wasters
we're not just here to just make a bunch
of videos like you don't have other
things to do we're not just here to just
spend all of our time online so you have
no time with your family we're here to
create a system
and create routines and habits
of content creation that lead us to our
financial goals and our legacy goals and
our family goals you need a system this
my friends is the system that changed my
life
this is the system i started to follow
10 years ago wasn't sexy at the time but
i just started to do the steps and do
the work and implement the habits and
the daily routines and video after video
upload after upload it was 10
subscribers
seven views you gotta you gotta respect
that seven view life
you know
you gotta respect that uploaded it took
you seven hours to edit the video
and you got seven views
and you're like
i know this is worth
i don't know this is worth my time
but it kind of sounds like for me last
time i went to the gym for an hour
which i haven't been to the gym for an
hour in a really long time
therefore i haven't been getting the
results
that when you first go like the results
don't show up immediately but as you
start working the system today think
media two million subscribers we've just
been working the system
today
thousands of our students are succeeding
just working the system
well i hope you are enjoying today's
session and i wanted to let you know
that if you are loving content like this
then you definitely need to go to
21videotips.com
where you can actually get 21 more video
marketing tips just like this from
industry experts like patrickbetdavid
vanessa lau pat flynn and alex hermozy
and so many amazing video marketers of
our day they're sharing their best kept
business building secrets inside of this
master class and free downloadable guide
so just head over to 21 tips
to get instant access for free and learn
how you can level up your business and
brand that's 21videotips.com
now let's get back into today's content
the first step is reverse engineer you
got to start with the end in mind i'm
going to go fast we will keep hitting it
throughout the conference
reverse engineer start with the end in
mind who's your channel actually for
like what are you even doing like who
what what is the vision and the goal of
your channel then we do research
what's trending in my niche right now
what's trending in real estate what's
changing in personal finance what's
trending in coaching what what is on
people's mind what's trending in culture
or keyword research we get clear that
we're actually making the right videos
then we've got to record the video we
want to record a video that's going to
keep people's attention then you got to
release the video the right way and
here's what i learned this system
i started out on youtube
but i was like wow this system actually
is the same for social media all the
platforms start with the end in mind get
clear on what your video idea is record
a great video release it the right way
does that include hashtags how's it
titled does it have a compelling reason
to click thumbnail what's the first few
seconds what's the frame like is it
released in the right way according to
the best practices of the platform then
rock it
rocket your video to success so for
every video the daily discipline the
habit the weekly discipline is
ultimately rocket the video share it out
on social media post that video on your
community tab can you get someone to
collaborate with on that video you got
an email let's send it to your email
list
then review
sometimes this isn't the funnest part
but it's probably the most important
part
because what gets measured gets improved
this is where when you get obsessed with
analytics you get obsessed with your
insights you get obsessed with looking
at your facebook page insights and and
studying what worked so you could get
one percent better with every upload and
improve next time and then it's about
repurpose
and repeat
now it's about thinking about okay i
made this video
but how can i actually use this
potentially in multiple places and how
can i begin again more intelligently
next time i upload content
and so we're going to kick it off today
just by starting with reverse engineer
which is start with the end in mind
best practice
in anything is before you start to think
about where do you want to go now
honestly on reverse engineer here's a
couple questions it's like who am i
trying to reach online what problem does
my content and business solve and how am
i going to make money and i know i'm
going fast but that's actually not what
i want to talk about with reverse
engineer
i actually want to take it a little bit
deeper and ask this question
what
do you want
like what do you want
well sean that's a what like what do you
mean
so what kind of what do you know like
what do you want
for lunch
for my birthday i mean uh why you're
since you're asking i mean maybe a new
car i mean no no i mean like what do you
want and i want you to actually journal
a little bit right now and write down
some things what do you want the funny
thing in this hyper world of social
media and online video growth and kind
of like looking at what everybody else
is doing sometimes we start to mirror
what we see online
and we don't even know why we're doing
it
like we're just like i don't know i'm
just trying to grow i'm trying to get
subscribers why
i don't know i'm just trying to i'm like
i'm trying to do what gary v told me to
do that's great but like why
like what
do you want
start writing it down deeper stuff like
what do you want in life and how can
online video help you get there can we
go deep and i would love if we could
journal a little bit like what do you
want in your business like what's the
clear end destination
that you want to reach
so that we can reverse engineer a plan
backward to get there
and i remember
when i felt the full impact of this
question back in 2009 when my wife
almost died
she was in the hospital for six days
recovering from almost a fatal accident
when she had a feeding tube from having
a chronic illness
and ultimately it was placed wrong so
the liquid started to fill up her body
cavity which will suffocate your organs
and it'll kill you quick
so we rushed her to the hospital and i
found my uh myself by my wife's side for
six days really thinking about some
heavy questions battling fear battling
depression and here's the crazy thing
about 2009
was that at this exact same time we're
getting crushed by the the big short and
the economic crash and the recession
we're losing our home we're losing a
rental property and i was part-time
staff at a church
and some senior leaders stole some money
and and there was a toxic leadership
culture and the whole thing started to
fall apart so now i find myself by my
wife's side in that hospital room
and i literally actually felt god asking
me a question like what do you want
like because i actually learned what
psychologists say i came to a moment
where i started to think about a lot
deeper life questions psychologists call
it mortality motivation
and friend i actually want to encourage
you
in the last two years
the whole world has been given this gift
because in the last two years we started
to think like
dude we might die
well actually here's the truth
uh we are gonna die
right and so i started to have this
question of like man what do i want
and i'll be honest with you like the
sean i was in that hospital room
obviously was not the sean i am standing
on this stage today
i
i wasn't super pumped about the man i
was
i was allowing my wife who was sick
to work multiple jobs
i was
insecure because i didn't know how to
make money and take care of my family
and i was scared
and so i honestly felt god asking me
this question like sean like what do you
want
and and all of a sudden my perspective
was different it was like
man i want a way to work from home
like
i want to love my wife better
i want to be a better leader than the
example of some of the leaders that had
let me down
like i want to figure this thing out
like i don't know how
but like
but i i i want i want to be around
people that are going to inspire me and
that are gonna that are they're gonna be
visionary and that are gonna be filled
like
i wanna be a better man i wanna impact
people i wanna teach i wanna make a
difference
i wanna make memories with my wife
because i don't know that if we'll ever
see tomorrow
all we ever have is today
and man we this happened so young in our
life we got married at 21.
she got sick at 23 we're in the hospital
we're 27 year olds
and we're having these kind of questions
like man
what do we really want what are we gonna
do and here's what's surprising
if you ask a lot of leaders like what do
you actually want
they can't give you a clear answer
i don't i don't blame you because
not a lot of times do we think this
deeply right
like
like where are you going where do you
want to go and here's here's what i want
to ask you like what do you ultimately
want reverse engineer what do you want
for your family
what do you want for your business
what what kind of impact do you want to
make on this world
let me ask you this
who do you want to be
seriously like like future cast like who
do you want to be reverse engineer let
me ask you this
who do you need
to become
in order to reach that vision that you
have
because the sean that was in that
hospital room was not
there yet and i had
to change some things get some help get
some coaching i had to go through a
process
who
do you need to be but there's a second
question as we land the plane that we
have to answer
and it's what do you have
what
do you have
and i felt like those are the two
questions because as i'm sitting in this
hospital room and i start thinking about
what do i want then it's like god's
asking me like what do you have
and i've noticed that there's three ways
to answer this question and two of them
are not very helpful
the first way you can answer this
question the question is not what do you
not have
right what do you have and you go well
sean well i don't have much money
okay
no like what do you have
well i don't have a fancy camera if i
had a fancy camera like
okay i mean chill but
like what do you have well i i don't
have a time
i don't got a team
well no the question is not what do you
not have right the questions what do you
have and i want you to brainstorm
because here's the truth it is not about
your resources it is about your
resourcefulness
but here's the second way you can answer
that question it's not what do you have
that sucks
right
well i'll tell you what i have i got a
bunch of debt
cool
all right i mean you know
well well i'll tell you what i have i
actually do have some employees
and they suck
if i had some good ones
what do you have
some single people are like well i don't
have a spouse yet some married people
are like well i do got a spouse and they
suck
too real
this is called the grasses greener
mentality
right
and i've learned this the grass is not
greener though on the other side the
grass is greener where you water it
[Music]
so what do you have
that's right
you gotta what else
your voice what else
knowledge
creativity
a message
an iphone that's right
yeah
what do you have you got the ability to
learn
come on you have you have the tenacity
to never quit what do you have i want
you to write that down because reverse
engineer is about auditing your
resources how am i going to use what i
have today be faithful with what i have
today so that i can ultimately
step into
what god has for me tomorrow and the
future of my business
well i hope that you enjoyed this
two-part series and i would love to know
what your aha moment was if you are
watching over on youtube or if you want
to rate and review this show you can do
that over on apple podcast and let us
know if you like content like this and
if you have not already been to
21videotips.com
i highly recommend that that be the next
place you go after listening to this
episode if you want to be learning some
of the latest little known secrets in
video marketing from experts like alex
or mozy patrickbetdavid vanessa lau and
so many more then you want to make sure
that you go to 21videotips.com
for our brand new free resource for you
there's a master class as well as a
downloadable guide to help walk you
through some of the secrets that have
never been shared before well thank you
so much for being a part of what we're
doing here at think media we have so
many great episodes in store for you so
make sure you stay locked here for every
single tuesday's drop and we'll see you
in the next episode bye
[Music]
you